a lot of pressure though this week as
the season gets toward the halfway point
the under pressure draft for Friday
first pick determined by the trivia
question today big cat asks me the
question which I will inevitably get
wrong okay here we go
Kirk Cousins completed eighty eight
point five percent of his passes last
night that broke the Vikings single game
record for completion percentage with a
minimum of 20 attempts whose record did
he break oh it's easy
it's got to be Sam Bradford because back
in 2016 3 yard passes to cut off on
every play it's actually Bradford that's
a good guess cuz I think he had the
completion record that year right
overall yet is Brett Favre in 2009 he
was 22 of 25 and week 11 against Seattle
that's fair for you to get d-lister than
that actually I'm gonna give you credit
even though you've been crying and
whining and pouting like a little child
all week because your trivia questions
are too hard I've heard I'm gonna give
you credit that was a tough question
because Sam Bradford would definitely be
the natural answer to that one yeah I
mean they've had like 75 quarterbacks in
their history how am I supposed to know
it was Brett Favre in one game in 2009
thank you big cat go ahead take the
first pick yeah okay here we go let's go
let's stay with the Bears the Bears Matt
naggy Mitch strabinsky you know what I
don't even think mr. burski is under
pressure because he kind of is what he
is at this point I think Matt Nagy's
under pressure because it's up to him to
keep this whole thing together this
weekend they need to beat the chargers
they need to do it in convincing fashion
if they want any chance to save this
season even with the win I'm not gonna
let myself you know get suckered in here
and think that the Bears are gonna be
one of those teams competing in the in
the top level of the NFC because they
just don't have enough it feels like
this year but this is a statement game
they need to have because if it doesn't
go well
look it's things could get real bad and
I saw Mike the Saints loss I think the
day before the Saints lost was the
four-year anniversary of the Bears
losing it
to the Dolphins when they got booted
halftime under Marc Trestman and Brandon
Marshall and Robbie Gould had a fight in
the locker room now I'm not saying
that's what's gonna happen here but
these things can go south quickly they
can go south quickly one teams that have
expectations don't live up to those
expectations so I think the Bears are
gonna win on Sunday I think Matt Nagy is
a very good coach but there's a lot of
pressure yeah and I agree with you
completely and if they don't win this
game it does fall apart if they win at 4
and 3 I mean what a difference between
three and five and they get to what
they've what are they right now
therefore 3 & 3 3 & 4
3 & 3 you get to 4 & 3 you get to 3 & 3
& 4 & 3 you're in good shape
4 & 3 you feel good you feel like you
had a chance and maybe you can fix some
of your problems and and be competitive
down the stretch
alright what I'm gonna do is I'm not
gonna go with the typical pressure like
our team is falling apart and you need a
big performance you need a big win the
pressure that that I think that is on
the shoulders of Andy Reed this weekend
is immense because ultimately he's the
guy who's gonna make the decision on
Patrick mahomes all the doctors make the
decision the trainer's make it enough
that the coach is the guy who's making
the decision and what the coach wants is
what the trainer's and the doctors will
say okay yeah we can make that work
mahomes wants to play why wouldn't he
want to play he's only gonna see Aaron
Rodgers once every four years unless
they meet in the Superbowl he wants to
square off against the best and he
thinks he's fine and he wants to go and
at the end of the day it's on Andy Reed
to make the right decision do you go
with Matt Moore and run the risk of
losing to the Packers or do you go with
Patrick mahomes increase your chance of
winning but also embrace the possibility
that there's going to be a reinjure e
and aggravation a new injury something
and it's all gonna be blamed on you if
something happens to the team's
franchise quarterback I wouldn't want to
have to make this decision if I'm Andy
Reed he's got a big decision big cat to
make by Sunday night let me ask you a
question Mike if Patrick mahomes is a
hundred percent healthy clear by the
doctors does any Reed have the Izzy is
he gonna say hey you know it even though
you're a hundred percent we're not going
to put you out there I think Andy Reed
can say no I'm not putting you out
I think the question is well the doctors
go along with what you know the kid
wants to play and the doctors say well
we got some well well okay do you want
to continue to be the doctor for the
Kansas City Chiefs then you'll sign off
on the kid playing that's kind of how
it's been in football forever as long as
he's not any of the heat you can see him
he's moving around he looks like he can
can at least do the job the question is
can he do it well enough to protect
himself will there be some fluke thing
that happens Andy Reid's got to be the
grown-up in the room here though the kid
wants to play the coach is the one who's
got to make the call and maybe they're
just trying to play the Jedi mind-trick
on the Packers and make them prepare for
both Matt Moore and Patrick mahomes
either way this thing has been set up
for Andy Reed to ultimately have to make
a really big decision and again I would
not want to have to make that decision
because I don't think there's any easy
answer to that question all right who
you got in round two okay round two I'm
going with Matt Patricia the Detroit
Lions Matt Patricia they've had a rough
couple of weeks they obviously had the
game on Monday night where they should
have won they got it stolen from them
they lose that one they get embarrassed
by the Vikings at home they lose by a
lot and give up a ton of yards then they
trade a team captain in quandary digs
and if you saw the reaction online they
were not happy that locker room was not
happy Darius slay was probably the most
vocal of the group but there were
multiple Lions who spoke out who were
baffled by that decision to trade a team
captain in the middle of the season when
your record isn't that bad when you
still have a chance to maybe compete for
a playoff spot so what that tells me is
this game will be a game where we'll
find out if the Lions are quitting on
this season or if they're going to rally
the troops and try to win this game and
and salvage something and Matt's effort
has been great this year so credit to
him but it is going to be on the
defensive side of the ball in Matt
Patricia that's the side he coaches will
he be able to get these guys rallied
even though they just traded their team
captain will they have a good
performance against a not great Giants
team if the Lions lose this game similar
to what we talked about the Eagles and
the Bears I think it gets worse before
it gets better
yeah long-term culture change that Matt
Patricia and Bob Quinn are trying to
implement in Detroit and really they
could have won each of the last three
games they could have beaten
the Chiefs they should have beaten the
Packers they could have beaten the
Vikings and now they desperately need to
beat a Giants team that has overmatched
I agree with you and and the decision to
trade quadrate digs it has not gone over
well in the locker room with guys who
really don't fit with the long-term
culture that they're trying to build
that's the problem though in the NFL
with the salary cap you can't just walk
through the door and say this guy's gone
this guy's gone this guy's gone there's
cap consequences you have to take into
account this contract that I've
guaranteed money so it's going to take
more time we'll Matt Patricia and Bob
Quinn have that time we'll see all right
next one for me it's got to be Baker
Mayfield of the two and for Cleveland
Browns with two weeks to get ready for
the New England Patriots the team that
had Sam Donald seeing ghosts on Monday
night and Baker Mayfield has not been
good this year for whatever reason you
can say the offensive line stinks you
can say that Freddie kitchens is now the
head coach and doesn't work with him as
much you can say the pressure getting
the ball to Odell Beckham jr. is messing
with Baker Mayfield regardless he hasn't
been good and if they lose this game
that fall to two and five in big cat as
you said earlier in the show their
schedule does soften later in the year
but by the time that happens it may be
too late and once they get a taste of
just what the Patriots really are and
what the difference is what the gap is
between the Patriots and the Browns that
may be the point where you mentioned
earlier that Bears defensive players may
eventually just say what's the point I
could see the Browns across the board
after they get buzzed sought by the
Patriots saying what's the point we're
never gonna compete with this team at
least not while Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick are around okay I actually
would say Freddie kitchens is more under
pressure in that scenario because he's
going up against Bill Belichick and he's
quoted as saying he's got things he
still has to learn which I don't I don't
think you ever want to say if you're a
head coach in the NFL my last one I'm
gonna go a little bit off the board here
Mike I'm gonna do something a little
different people are probably saying
themselves always gonna pick the Eagles
we talked about Doug Peterson keeping
that whole thing together against the
bills in Buffalo no I'm not gonna do
that Mike we could probably say hey he's
gonna do Sam Donald because he saw a
ghost like last week and what will
happen this week when he's you know
going back to Jack going down to
Jacksonville
will there be ghosts in Jacksonville
nope I'm not gonna do that Mike I'm
going too
make drew brees drew brees is under
pressure this week because whether you
whether you want to admit it or not guys
are competitive people watch people see
it's drew Brees team he still is the guy
in New Orleans but Teddy Bridgewater has
been fantastic they have won all their
games since he started no one really
expected them to win all of their games
you know thinking if you look to the
schedule after Drew Brees hurt his thumb
going to Chicago going to Seattle those
are games that you said wow those they
teddy bridgewater won't be able win
those playing against Dallas who was
undefeated at the time I think there's
gonna be a little pressure on Drew Brees
because if he comes in and that offense
takes a step back in any way people are
gonna start asking questions were they
better with Teddy Bridgewater than Drew
Brees now and that's not that far
outside of the box that would have been
my next pick if you hadn't taken Drew
Brees because it feels like he's trying
to kind of barge his way back out onto
the field and and for a guy who's been
very good with optics over the course of
his career the way it's played out this
week the casual observer could listen to
the things he said listen to the things
Sean Payton said and get the impression
that Drew Brees is taking his job back
regardless of whether he's ready or not
because you said earlier in the show
it's the Cardinals right the Cardinals
have won three in a row they haven't
beaten anybody this Teddy Bridgewater
led Saints team should be able to easily
beat the Cardinals then you have your
bye week then you bring Drew Brees back
for essentially the triple a rehab game
against the Falcons that's how it should
work so I agree with you even though
this has been the target all along the
fact that they've gone five and O
without Drew Brees makes it easier to
say let's just go ahead and push this
through the bye week let's not take any
chances and if he does play the
pressures on him to play well and win
could you imagine if he would play and
they would lose to the Cardinals that
would not be the ideal way to spend the
two weeks of their bye all right last
one for me and this is a guy that I said
before the year is an MVP candidate if
he can stay healthy and that's equals
quarterback Carson Wentz the problem is
no one else on the team has stayed
healthy and he hasn't played well enough
now again he doesn't have the team
around him they don't commit to the run
the way that they should and I think
what they're trying to do big cat and
and this was the problem last year with
the Eagles when Carson Wentz played they
would
so infatuated by his physical abilities
that they would have him run the ball
and do things that weren't really part
of the offense per se they is almost
like the Cam Newton factor hey this guy
is a beast he's physically gifted let's
let him just go do his thing this year I
think they're trying to wedge him more
into the offense and it's just not
working because it worked so well when
they wedge Nick Foles into the offense
and Malcolm Jenkins made a comment this
week that was almost like hey we're a
better team with Nick Foles and that's
what I said last year Carson Wentz is
better quarterback they're a better team
with Nick Foles they're trying too hard
to make Carson Wentz into a system type
of a guy this is the week he's got to
step up and say I'm gonna do whatever I
have to do to win the game even if I
have to throw caution to the wind even
if I risk getting injured this is a win
that the Eagles must have they've got to
get the four and four if they're gonna
have any chance down the stretch against
some of the teams they're gonna play
pressures on Carson Wentz okay I like
that pick Mike the other thing with the
Eagles you have the nick foles thing
where they had success with Nick Foles
the last two years and Carson Wentz got
injured the other part of it is what
look what Frank Reich is doing over in
Indianapolis and he was part of that
coaching staff when they won the Super
Bowl and you always have this happen
where a guy leaves has success somewhere
else and everyone says wait was he the
guy or was it the guy that is staying
here in Doug Peterson and I like Doug
Peterson but that is always a question
that gets thrown out there so they have
a double Frank Reich and Nick Foles
saying was he the guys that the guy
who's still here
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports